marioupol ville fantôme assiégée depuis
des semaines et réduite en poussière par
les bombardements russes des milliers de
morts une situation humanitaire
catastrophique
natalia a réussi à quitter cette ville
portuaire sur la mer d'azov avec son
fils et pour lui
il ne supportait plus les bombardements
il lui a dit qu'il voulait vivre raconte
t-elle non sans regret car elle a laissé
derrière elle beaucoup d'enfants seuls
cent par an est décrit une ville sans
eau sans nourriture sans électricité
pour sergey le traumatisme des cadavres
jonchant la ville est encore vif en vue
de recruter
2 j'ai vu comment les missiles grad
frappé les maisons et déchiqueter les
humains raconte-t-il si l'on réussit à
partir des centaines de milliers de
civils sont toujours bloqués sans aucune
garantie des russes de pouvoir évacuer
en sécurité ce qui est vraiment
important pour les russes d'avoir mario
pole parce que leur objectif c'est de
faire le lien entre le monde passe
jusqu'à la crimée qu'on n'utilise
malheureusement décidé comme cible
volontaires pour gagner des gains et
militaires pour faire plier l'armée à
l'ukrainienne qui considèrent mario à
irbine au nord-ouest de la capitale kiev
les nouvelles du front sont meilleurs
pour l'instant massoni après innover ne
se renie en ville mais ils pin
mais rose au mim selon la ceni ce
tabouret chien n'a pas de
un répit pour les résidents de la ville
qui fuient la guerre et les combats
féroces des derniers jours ir pin aurait
été reprise à l'envahisseur
nicolas yves a vu les taux russe se
desserrer une victoire ukrainienne
synonyme d'un changement de stratégie
militaire du kremlin la raison pour
laquelle la russie change de stratégie
pour se concentrer dans l'est du pays
c'est précisément en raison des
victoires crédit en raison de la
résistance acharnée en raison de leur
capacité à vraiment attaquer les chaînes
d'approvisionnement
à proximité de la ligne de front karkhiv
et pilonnés de façon quasi quotidienne
ce quartier est une cité martyre où les
survivants se terre dans le noir le
froid et la faim
à la veille d'un nouveau chapitre de
négociation le président zelensky étudie
l'exigence russe de neutralité mais veut
des garanties de sécurité si l'ukraine
ne rejoint pas l'otan il faut que
l'europe et y assure à la protection de
l'ukraine c'est un accord de cession
avec les rouges parce que il est tout à
fait envisageable que les russes trop
fines chez celles qui ravitaille et leur
trop et lancé une nouvelle offensive ce
soir le président ukrainien urgent les
pays occidentaux de renforcer des
sanctions contre moscou et d'imposer dès
maintenant l'embargo sur le pétrole
russe ici au smic rails at radio canada
montréal